[Música]
novena cumbre de las américas la primera
en la que eeuu es el país anfitrión
desde que comenzaron a celebrarse estos
encuentros en
1994 tras una convocatoria hecha por el
entonces presidente de eeuu bill clinton
esta novena versión que tiene como lema
construyendo un futuro sostenible
resiliente y equitativo no ha escapado a
la controversia porque el país
organizador dejó por fuera de su
invitación a países como cuba nicaragua
y venezuela cuál fue el argumento pues
para washington son países que no
respetan la carta democrática de las
américas en resumen no respetan los
valores democráticos a los ojos de eeuu
y por lo tanto no son bienvenidos pese
al esfuerzo del presidente mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador para mediar
en esta situación washington se mantuvo
en su posición razón que llevó a que el
mandatario mexicano declinar a su
invitación veamos
y no voy a la cumbre
porque no se invita a todos los países
de américa y yo
creo
la necesidad
de cambiar la política
que se ha venido
imponiendo desde hace siglos
y no puede haber cumbre de las américas
si no
participan
todos los países
del continente
americano así las cosas méxico estará
representado por marcelo ebrard su
canciller eeuu respeto la decisión del
gobierno mexicano escuchemos
señores
señor presidente dolor
si de muertos
el tema de las constantes violaciones de
los proyectos humanos en cuba en
particular pero también el mejor agua y
venezuela es algo que preocupa al señor
presidente los shoppings
en su momento bolivia brasil y
argentina- también amenazaron con no
asistir a la cumbre pero el presidente
brasileño jair bolsonaro pronto bajó el
tono cuando le ofrecieron tener una
reunión privada con el presidente bailén
en el marco de la cumbre lo mismo
sucedió con alberto fernández de
argentina cuando la casa rosada- recibió
una invitación para hacer una visita
oficial a washington para el mes de
julio a esto también hay que sumar que
el presidente de uruguay luis lacalle
pou tampoco asistirá pero esta vez por
razones médicas el gobierno uruguayo
indicó que el mandatario dio positivo
para kobe 19 y por lo tanto no podrá
asistir a esta cumbre
la controversia desde ya deja un mal
sabor de boca sobre las expectativas que
hay sobre este encuentro es lamentable
ver que el evento es noticia por los
anuncios de quién va a asistir o quién
no va a asistir sobre todo en un momento
en que la región necesita verse unida
entre países mostrar compromisos
liderazgos para hacer frente en conjunto
para la recuperación después de la
pandemia de kobe 19 que afectó por igual
a todos los países también vale la pena
analizar temas como el populismo el
retroceso democrático la migración la
seguridad y la creciente pues
inseguridad alimentaria que también está
afectando tanto américa latina'
esto deja entonces a su vez preguntas
sobre el estado de las relaciones
hemisféricas como es hoy en día la
relación de eeuu con américa latina cómo
está la región ante la llegada de
presencia ante la llegada y la presencia
perdón de potencias extrarregionales
como por ejemplo china o como por
ejemplo rusia cómo está el estado de la
democracia la relación político
ideológica hay una agenda común
fortalecida que hay de temas
transversales como los mencionaba ahora
la pobreza el narcotráfico que también
lo estaba diciendo hace unos minutos son
muchas las preguntas que quedan sobre la
mesa por eso hoy en el debate de france
24 una cumbre de las américas dividida
es nuestro tema para analizar y para
conversar sobre ese tema saludamos a
maría guadalupe gonzález ella es
profesora asociada del colegio méxico
ella se encuentra en la capital mexicana
y desde la ciudad de buenos aires en
argentina se conecta a esta conversación
mónica hearst ella es profesora en el
instituto de estudios sociales y
políticos de la universidad de río de
janeiro y también de la universidad
torcuato di tella las dos bienvenidas al
programa gracias por acompañarnos y
también ustedes nuestros televidentes
hacen parte de esta conversación a
través de las redes sociales pueden
dejar sus comentarios en facebook en
instagram y en twitter pueden ver
también nuestra señal a través de
nuestro canal en youtube en nuestra
señal en streaming nos encuentra como
france24 guión bajo es santi logo que es
mi cuenta personal nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todas
sus preguntas y sus comentarios comienzo
entonces con el mar y hago lupe
nacionales de méxico dándole la
bienvenida gracias por acompañarnos en
maría guadalupe y me gusta llamar a esta
primera pregunta al debate el punto de
partida
en ese punto de partida pues es
precisamente la frase con la que cerraba
la introducción esta cumbre de las
américas deja en evidencia una américa
fragmentada cuál es su opinión
por completo esta cumbre las américas
con toda la controversia que hemos
venido viendo en los últimos meses es
básicamente el espejo del estado de la
región no solamente estamos en el
momento quizás más bajo de interlocución
entre eeuu de américa latina desde los
años noventas sino que además también
estamos en una situación en la que los
presidentes latinoamericanos entre sí
tampoco se hablan tampoco se coordina
estamos viendo un momento en el que gran
parte de los mecanismos de integración y
de concertación política en la región
están inoperantes vimos hace poco por la
desaparición de
unasur y su sustitución por pro sur hay
una ideologización de la organización de
los estados americanos por otro lado hay
también un estancamiento de la alianza
del pacífico en si la región está más
dividida que nunca fragmentada y a pesar
de que hay
y mecanismos instituciones que se
encuentran ahí pero no hay en este
momento una voz común ni siquiera
conversaciones con respecto a qué agenda
llevar a esta cumbre entonces realmente
esto es lo que estamos mismo módica
haste en la ciudad de buenos aires
también le doy la bienvenida del
programa y la pregunta del punto de
partida es la misma para las dos cumbre
de las américas una américa dividida y
fragmentada cuál es su opinión
si no estoy totalmente de acuerdo con lo
que decía guadalupe a causa de punto de
vista del estado del momento en que
estamos en el momento de fragmentación y
diferencias pero también creo que es
importante entender de causa porque
estamos en esta situación con respecto a
la cumbre particularmente en una
secuencia de
situaciones de quiebra de desasosiego de
desencuentro del propio inter
americanismo no sea la relación de eeuu
con la región que se viene deteriorando
digamos con ya con algún tiempo pero que
se está deteriorado
este deterioro este profundiza y
profundizó muchísimo durante el gobierno
trump y de ninguna manera pero de
ninguna manera el gobierno bailan este y
su cualquier tipo de esfuerzo para
revertir este deterioro entonces de
repente hasta la cumbre que durante
varios meses no sabía no sé quiero es el
que se iba a dar si realmente iba a
ocurrir porque había tal vacío de punto
de vista de washington y derecho de cómo
va a seguir habiendo este vacío porque
de washington a los ángeles son casi
cinco horas de vuelo en esta cumbre no
llega a washington las sociedades
latinoamericanas van a llegar a la
cumbre y están activamente llegando pero
el gobierno norteamericano y el gobierno
pensado incluso en términos digamos no
solamente de la casa blanca pero el
congreso también
va a estar apenas presente
y esto sí como joseba he vertido
y maría guadalupe quiero que
profundicemos en los factores que han
llevado a esta fragmentación ya ustedes
lo están mencionando no es solamente
para esta cumbre la fragmentación se
viene presentando desde antes digamos
que esta cumbre como que lo puso sobre
la mesa y nos puso a analizar qué es lo
que está pasando pero a qué se debe esta
fragmentación entonces ausencia de un
liderazgo una crisis de liderazgo en la
región
también desconexión entre el norte y el
sur es esta la consecuencia de esa
desconexión que sembró el gobierno trump
desde washington hacia la región cuál es
el análisis que usted puede hacer
si hay una falta de liderazgo tanto de
por parte de estados unidos hacia la
región que tiene como base sobre todo el
estado de una decisión interna y el
legado que deja también este regreso al
nacionalismo tanto económico como
político en los eeuu
recordemos que el legado de trump es
básicamente recuerden ustedes su lema
era america first entonces era ver
primero por los eeuu ya dice de todos
los sistemas multilaterales y en ese
sentido actuar de una manera unilateral
y en defensiva bailén trata de darle
vuelta un poquito a esto pero como hay
tal con la iniciación y no tiene digamos
mayoría completa en el senado para poder
sacar adelante todo su programa lo
cierto es que algunas de las cosas que
ha intentado débilmente pues no han
aterrizado entonces de eeuu no hay una
oferta no hay migración
eeuu tiene la casa en desorden y eeuu
están divididos no saben qué hacer ni
que quieren con américa latina' otro
lado del lado latinoamericano pues que
tenemos tenemos una enorme diversidad y
ver gencia en términos de condiciones
político ideológicas en el poder que
tienen modelos distintos de desarrollo
perspectivas distintas de lo que debe
hacerse para salir adelante y ante esta
situación pues también hay poco diálogo
internet y no americano y tenemos otro
grave problema en realidad es que los
dos países grandes de alguna forma
tampoco están muy hacia adelante para
ejercer un liderazgo en el caso de
brasil pues consultaron prácticamente
renunció no a una que a un brasil con
una política exterior asertiva y del
lado de méxico en realidad el presidente
alterno del obrador originalmente ha
dicho siempre que la mejor política
exterior en la política interna y cuando
han buscado cierto liderazgo ha sido muy
selectivo y sin digamos cierta
consistencia y de mediano y largo plazo
entonces tenemos necesariamente una
déficit de líder a sus trucos es un
fracaso importante y vemos que el
presidente mexicano se ha mantenido
digamos que en su zona más cómoda que es
haber hecho presencia en centroamérica
que son sus países más cercanos y donde
méxico tiene mucha influencia y su
principal socio comercial que es eeuu ha
habido una fluida digamos en relación
entre washington y méxico en diferentes
reuniones por diferentes problemas en
común entre ambos países pasó a
preguntarle ahora a mónica en la ciudad
de buenos aires
aparte de estos factores que mencionaba
maría guadalupe cuáles más podemos
añadir y qué tanto entra en a
profundizar esta situación crisis y lo
podemos llamar así de liderazgo a nivel
regional la coyuntura que estamos
viviendo países que estamos sacando de
una pandemia reactivando la economía una
guerra en europa y la presencia y la
atención de china y rúsia en a nivel
global
y son muchos los factores desde
animadores no es cierto
por un lado
están digamos estas estas situaciones
específicas de la región está la enorme
picamos el nombre vacío en el diálogo
entre el norte y el sur
está digamos la penuria con que estamos
saliendo de la pandemia no es cierto una
penuria con un costo social altísimo un
costo social que parecería en un primer
momento que se podría revertir con
índices de crecimiento de cooperación
que podrían digamos que parecerían que
vendrían con más esté más impulso y
ahora los números ya muestran los
indicadores demuestran que este impulso
viene bajando o sea la exclusión social
en américa latina hoy día llega a nuevos
inti índices ya nuevos números que hacen
digamos muy difícil que soluciones
políticas dentro de un marco democrático
pueda realmente digamos construirse con
bases más sólidas de la representación
política enfrenta muchas crisis en la
región
bueno y en eeuu también ahora además
tenemos la consultura de la guerra no la
guerra esté producida este en europa
producida este a partir de la de la
invasión a ucrania el impacto
de esta guerra y la el tipo de respuesta
que el occidente da la guerra aquí es un
aumento extraordinario de
presupuesto militar en todos lados
y obviamente todo significa digamos que
cuando uno pone más plata y más recursos
en este tipo de prioridad es que las
agendas sociales económicas propiamente
indicaciones entre ricas nuestra región
es una región postergada por eeuu hace
mucho tiempo y está en guerra sólo va a
producir más porte gas ya hablar mónica
de más que eran presupuestos de agendas
sociales y educativas que ya venían
afectados precisamente por la pandemia
porque muchos recursos habían sido
destinados para comprar vacunas para
adecuar hospitales para dar cubrimiento
a esta emergencia continuó con mónica
para hacer la ronda a la inversa y usted
menciona la relación de eeuu mencionaba
ese distanciamiento que hay de
washington con latinoamérica
cómo está la relación de desconexión
y grave preocupante esa desconexión que
hay entre washington y américa latina o
es
existe la posibilidad de empezar a
mejorarla a partir de escenarios como
por ejemplo esta cumbre en la ciudad de
los ángeles
bueno el tema acá es saber cómo se va a
recuperar
no hablo de vínculo
hay una preocupación geopolítica de
estados unidos hoy día muy fuerte con
respecto a la relación a la presencia
perdón
económica política y militar
tecnológica de china sabemos muy bien
que china es un actor con una creciente
relevancia para muchos yo diría que para
casi todos los países la región de punto
de vista de lo que representa como el
mercado para las commodities con lo que
representa de punto de vista de
posibilidades de acceso a tecnología de
punta y obvian es de punto desde las
propias inversiones y si eeuu encima de
la negligencia la desidia
empieza a percibir esta presencia china
como una amenaza a sus intereses y no
logra hacer de esta presencia una
construcción positiva este una con una
rivalidad competitiva
y esto obviamente va a generar nuevas
tensiones y va a generar
rockstar
contraproducente que son nuestras élites
utilizando los intereses de eeuu como
parte de sus pugnas políticas internas
maría guadalupe en ciudad de méxico
vemos al presidente de byd en actuando
de una forma muy
digámoslo despaciosa en cuanto a las
relaciones con américa latina pero vemos
que luego hace unos movimientos rápidos
como por ejemplo esos nuevos
acercamientos con la habana y con
caracas también en el marco de la
coyuntura que se está dando con la
guerra en ucrania y el posicionamiento
de rusia en esos dos países que es lo
que impide el presidente de byd en
actuar un poco más rápido tal vez sea
ese escenario político las elecciones de
medio término la amplia bancada
republicana en el congreso que tal vez
le frena un poco sus intereses y por eso
su política exterior hacia américa
latina es como tan errática algunas
veces que no tal vez no la entiende muy
claro
creo que es muy buena la pregunta cuando
estabas eeuu actúa rápidamente cuando ve
intereses geopolíticos en juego qué
ocurre en el caso del acercamiento del
ajuste que pudo haber habido desde el
punto de vista pragmático con cuba o
venezuela ni salís ucrania es
precisamente la necesidad no de
compensar la posible pérdida de energía
que tiene que ver con el tema de la
guerra en europa entonces cuando hay
intereses materiales y políticos en
juego qué es lo que ocurre que el
comandante en jefe que es el presidente
los eeuu tienen cierta capacidad
delegada para actuar relativamente y hay
cierto consenso o digamos o la gente en
general tiende a este fenómeno que en
eeuu se llama the valley around start no
es decir cuando se trata de este tema de
guerra entonces se tienen se tiende a
dar más un cheque en blanco de corto
plazo a los presidentes pero los genes
el resto en los temas de la agenda que
básicamente serían las haciendas blandas
por decirlo de alguna manera que tienen
que ver con américa latina en temas de
desarrollo etcétera pues tiende a
prevalecer sobre todo muchas veces
intereses de política exterior y hay
temas de la relación de eeuu con américa
latina que están secuestrados por temas
de política exterior dimensión o
básicamente dos que tienen que ver con
el tema migratorio y segundo lo que
tiene que ver con la relación con cuba
por el tema tan importante del voto
va a ser crucial para las elecciones
de medio término en noviembre entonces
hay temas de la agenda que están
secuestrados por la política intendencia
es una primera cosa de uno además ya lo
mencionaba usted y me parece muy
importante que en el américa latina se
entienda y se comprenda en la
profundidad de la crisis política y de
desorden disfuncionalidad por la cual
está atravesando el sistema político en
eeuu no estamos acostumbrados a ver en
eeuu tan desordenado estar con la casa
verdaderamente en desorden y tiene que
ver simplemente para dar un indicador al
día de hoy después de hace un año en el
poder el presidente y bailén no han
logrado que el senado ratifique a su
embajador ante la organización de
estados americanos no tienen embajadores
ratificados en un tercio de las
embajadas en el mundo en américa latina
no tiene embajador en brasil hace cuatro
años que no tiene embajador en chile y
todo esto porque está de alguna manera
republicanos o por otros intereses
dentro mismo del partido demócrata pues
no avanzan entonces vemos esta situación
de un presidente que está un poco
amarrado además de que también está
dividido internamente su administración
el departamento de estado está relegado
o son digamos las instancias de
seguridad que llevan van hacia adelante
o la casa blanca
entonces ante esta situación con un
desorden interno pues va lento y seguirá
yendo lento si pasamos ahora ya lo
estamos mencionando la presencia de
china en nuestra región ya para muchos
países de américa latina y china es su
principal socio comercial hay muchos
países haciendo grandes esfuerzos para
concertar agendas para tratados libres
de libre comercio vemos por ejemplo el
caso de uruguay que está en una
negociación con beijing desde hace ya
varios meses poniendo el riesgo
precisamente mucho del marco del
mercosur pero pues defendiendo sus
intereses pasó a preguntarle a mónica es
por la presencia de esas potencias
extrarregionales que tanto peso han
ganado que tanto teme eeuu usted ya daba
unos pisos de la presencia china acá en
términos militares comerciales y
políticos
y yo creo que
no
es una es sorprendente como hay una
especie de yo diría una dramatización de
esta presencia
que viene creciendo hace 20 años hace 22
décadas que teníamos esta presencia este
para partir de lo que nos llamó en su
momento el boom de las commodities
y obviamente y además sabemos muy bien
que yo no soy economista pero la
importancia aquí fue que fueron digamos
los altos índices de crecimiento de la
economía china para toda la economía
mundial
y especialmente para las economías de lo
que uno llama del psuv global
necesitamos
la idea de la transformación de esta
presencia en una amenaza ya o política
es obviamente una construcción política
que tendrá digamos yo no estoy atada de
ninguna manera y no sentando la lo que
viene a ser la gran estrategia china
pero lo que quiero decir es que esto
digamos ha penetrado ya el punto de
vista de lo que son las los intereses lo
que son la construcción de posibilidades
en ética de articulación de los países
de nuestra región en cadena de valor y
esto digamos y la vinculación con china
es parte hoy día de las posibilidades
del amigo de nuestras economías soy yo
digamos criticar ya que la
reprimarización de varias de las
economías latinoamericanas e incluso la
brasilera este han sido muy
problemáticas en función de este vínculo
no sé yo no estoy acá tratando de
defender un desarrollo este en relación
a otro lo que es increíble es que es muy
empobrecedor transformar este vínculo
con este la economía china
como una amenaza ya política que es lo
que nos guía todo el gobierno pero una
parte importancia de la administración y
de la clase política
y bien tratado claro estábamos pasando
un poco más allá de la mitad del
programa maría guadalupe algo que decir
en torno a esta presencia de china en
américa latina para luego ya hablar de
la agenda común y los temas de
democracia en la región
bueno a mí me parece que esa es una
presencia que es inestable para muchos
efectos por el hecho de que en realidad
de alguien hay una complementariedad
entre las economías sobre todo
contienen en la economía china acá de lo
que se trata básicamente de que los
países latinoamericanos que tienen esta
complementariedad con china que no es el
caso de méxico porque méxico en realidad
tiene una relación de competencia con
china están compitiendo quedamos por el
mercado más importante del mundo que es
el de eeuu entonces área de querer esas
diferencias la presencia de china no es
lo mismo no significa lo mismo para los
países de centroamérica del caribe y de
mexico que para los países sudamericanos
entonces este es un primer punto porque
en realidad hay mayor complementariedad
entre los países norteamericanos de unos
centroamericanos y cambian los respecto
a eeuu mientras que los países
sudamericanos tienen mayor
complementariedad con respecto a china
acá es tema para américa latina es
principalmente el verde que forma no
caer en en esta trampa de china como el
competidor estratégico porque américa
latina no debiera estar en ésta
tesitura de tener que optar por uno o
por otro porque en realidad pues américa
latina' debiera poder optar por aquel
inversionista o por aquella tecnología
que realmente es la que le da mayores
ventajas ya que es en donde eeuu en
realidad se ha quedado con otra en su
oferta lo que pasa quiere un poquito que
nosotros compremos esta idea de que
chile es un peligro y ciertamente puede
haber perdido este ecológico
7 es un hecho pero más allá de eso pues
no está digamos ofreciendo condiciones
por ejemplo de comercio de hecho ahorita
no hay condiciones políticas en eeuu
para que se abra un nuevo tratado de
comercio que quisiera el ecuador uruguay
con eeuu porque políticamente son tabú
flavia y tampoco hay una oferta de
grandes inversiones en infraestructura
se andó pero eso no está allí entonces
se necesita llegar a la cumbre cuando
hermanos vacías simplemente alertando a
los países de la queratina y bien el
nuevo pero sí vamos generar ninguna
contra pan común claro pero las
necesidades de américa latina' los hacen
a los países caer ante la seducción de
china para sobre todo para el tema
infraestructuras que es una de las
grandes problemáticas en la región
pasemos a hablar entonces de esa agenda
común que hay para los países por lo
menos para la región de américa latina
en esta última parte del programa muchos
temas se vienen tratando desde hace
nueve cumbres atrás hablamos de temas
transversales como la pobreza la
desigualdad inseguridad el narco ahora
está cogiendo cada vez más fuerza en
otros países como por ejemplo ecuador
veíamos los problemas que también están
viviendo en paraguay y bueno países que
ya están consolidados en esa industria
digámoslo así como colombia venezuela y
méxico los mismos temas agendas y
mirarles similares y poca evolución
porque no hay un diálogo común para
hablar sobre estos temas porque no hay
un consenso cuando es un problema que le
afecta a todos comenzó preguntándole a
mónica
y bueno
el tema que también es saber consenso
entre quienes porque
si estamos hablando de gobiernos
totalmente de acuerdo que hay un vacío
interno del multilateralismo
latinoamericano
y digamos qué hacer
obviamente es resultado de una
dificultad de un impulso constructivo de
diálogo en los temas que usted mencionó
pero las sociedades estén
latinoamericanas están muy activas y
yo diría y hemos trabajado en incluso
proyectos de encuesta de opinión pública
de la profesora guadalupe yo y ya sin
trabajos recientes donde lo que
percibimos es que las sociedades
latinoamericanas
están preocupadas están
interesadas y están informadas sobre la
agenda internacional y no piensan de una
manera muy diferente cuando tienen que
indicar cuáles son los principales
problemas cuáles son los principales
socios cuáles son los principales
liderazgos internacionales entonces
digamos
yo diría que lo que existe más en este
momento es un vacío y una brecha un gap
no entre está la voz de nuestras
sociedades y la capacidad de nuestros
gobiernos realmente vehicular estas
voces en una construcción política
institucional
vertebrada y
identifique los intereses comunes y las
principales dolencias porque acá no es
un tema de obviamente que la
planificación de que el largo plazo es
muy importante sólo nosotros estamos en
situaciones de emergencia emergencia en
algunos casos humanitarios claro y ahí
pero hace falta esa coordinación alinear
esos programas con esas demandas
sociales y esas demandas ciudadanas que
hemos visto se han incrementado en los
últimos meses o por lo menos en el
último par de años aquí en américa
latina
maría guadalupe su opinión sobre este
tema la agenda común porque nos cuesta
tanto fortalecer la región para unificar
planes cuando tenemos prácticamente las
mismas necesidades millones de pobres en
nuestra región por ejemplo
hay un problema
histórico que en general de las grandes
iniciativas
interamericanas han venido se han
construido desde washington hacia el sur
y no a la inversa y entonces ya lo decía
mónica
siempre los temas que tienen que ver con
las sociedades latinoamericanas quedan
relegadas a lo que son los intereses de
los eeuu este es el momento en ese
sentido de oportunidad por varias
razones la primera es que esta es una
coyuntura en la cual el tema de
desigualdad de pobreza de rezago social
debilidad de los sistemas de salud son
problemas compartidos tanto entre dos
países de américa latina como entre los
pan como con eeuu y canadá
tampoco las cosas están bien en este
sentido en eeuu y aquí hay cierto eco
entre el llamado de la sociedad para
poner los temas de desigualdad los temas
sociales en el centro de las agendas
tanto en política interna como de
política exterior otro asunto que tiene
que ver con el hecho de que lo que hace
falta es construir narrativas
cooperativas y pongo un ejemplo en el
tema de inseguridad y de narcotráfico
hasta ahora hemos estado
entrampados en todo el paradigma
prohibicionista y son estrategias que
han fallado una y otra vez porque de
prohibicionismo lo que ha hecho es
incrementar las ganancias del crimen
organizado que es el que finalmente pues
sigue adelante este mercado
y este es un momento interesante en
donde si podrían empatar los intereses
de la administración bailen con los
intereses de los países de américa
latina para darle un giro distinto a
cómo atender el tema de las drogas ya la
administración baila en ha puesto sobre
la mesa la idea de sentarse sobre todo
en políticas de prevención y de control
digamos de reducción de daños es decir
atacar principalmente el tema de el
condado como como un problema de salud
pública entonces hace falta quien
construya esas narrativas cooperativas
no y aquí de nuevo volvemos al tema de
los liderazgos como no hay liderazgos a
nivel gubernamental que estén planteando
de esta manera más innovadora pues hacia
el momento en el que la sociedad
significa organizar y es por esta razón
digamos que nosotras mismas hemos venido
trabajando a través de un informe que
acabamos de entregar ahora en la cumbre
las américas con la idea de proponer que
efectivamente en los siguientes tres
años que sin dañar diligencia y la
cumbre
hay solamente un tema y no otro tema más
el tema de el combate de la desigualdad
y reducir las brechas si ahí tenemos
todos los tonos de todos los esfuerzos
en ese sentido vamos a poder entonces
encontrar quizá las soluciones técnicas
a estos problemas
poco a poco me queda poco más de un
minuto para finalizar el programa maría
guadalupe mónica quiero que hagamos las
con la conclusión del programa lo que
ustedes creen que va a salir de esta
cumbre siempre lo digo no tenemos la
bola de cristal para saber qué va a
pasar en el futuro que va a surgir de
estas reuniones pero desde su análisis y
del conocimiento que ya han expuesto
aquí en el programa comienzo con mónica
su
conclusión que puede salir de esta
cumbre
y yo creo que de la cumbre mismo muy
poco o nada
esto es un capítulo más de la secuencia
de
desencuentros y de descompás os
interaméricas del sistema interamericano
pero creo también que la vitalidad
social que va a aparecer durante esta
cumbre va a ser un capital político muy
importante tanto para los simonico y
estas decisiones como los que piensan
sobre la política interna holanda de
américa latina maria guadalupe en su
conclusión
yo también creo que va a salir poco de
este hombre alguna alguna acuerdo con
respecto a cambio climático
probablemente donde hay mayor
convergencia quizá se ha hablado algo
que ha venido manejando el presidente
boris y que ha venido proponiendo
creación de acuerdos para protección de
todo es pacífico eso puede suceder pero
son acuerdos puntuales y me parece que
lo más importante de esta cumbre es que
estamos toca el fondo y es un llamado de
atención y en ese sentido doy la
bienvenida a todas estas controversias
porque efectivamente hace mucho que hay
negligencia y ahora ha quedado claro que
de la negligencia sólo queda vacío y se
dice que en estas sociedades no se
merecen eso pues con estas palabras nos
quedamos maría guadalupe y mónica muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 en toda américa
latina ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través de
las redes sociales y por supuesto con
nuestra programación siga con nosotros
[Música]